Diego congratulations on this series my
man it looks amazing so far
thank you so much for watching
you know
as an actor when you're finding your
character right you've got to create
their whole world like their likes or
dislikes their inner monologue their
backstory is this story in Andor the
same backstory you imagined for him when
you were first finding him in Rogue one
I I would say in essence it is yes I
mean we obviously this is the take that
that Tony Gilroy brought and and this is
his his idea uh for the show and the
specificity
I can't say is the same yeah but but in
essence it is you know because uh uh I
think I think when I when I when I had
to build the backstory for the character
that no one asks for you know those
questions in in Rogue one don't get
answered but I needed the answer because
you know that's that's my job you know
you need to understand why you make a
choice and it has to be logical for you
uh but that is in essence it's it's very
similar to what Tony had in mind that's
why I was so uh shocked and and happy
and excited to join because he's his his
story was very much uh in tune with what
I thought cassian's background was uh
but at the same time I was impressed you
know when he when he brought the
material the richness uh the specificity
uh the the the past of Cassian is is
full of of of of an energy that I
connected with immediately you know I
was like wow that's amazing that makes
sense he's Samantha has been forced to
move you know he he's been migrating
from one place to another he he is a
refugee you know and no one answers that
question in Rogue one why why does
cousin have such a different accent than
everyone else where is he coming from
what was his past well what did he leave
behind you know all of those questions
will be answered now
what do you think fans will be most
surprised by in this particular story
I think it
that that is very different from
everything else they've seen I think in
in in Star Wars you know uh at least
recently it tonally in fact we are
supposed to be different that is the
idea you know it's like what Rogue one
represented uh before you know there was
this film that it was a standalone that
could be its own that had a beginning
and an end well with this series is the
same you know in the world of serieses
of Star Wars and everything coming out
we have a beginning and an end we cannot
go forever because we know there's an
ending for this role and and we're just
gonna tell you what happened five years
before Rogue one uh so it's just these
two seasons of 24 episodes 12 each and
uh and we are allowed to have a
different tone uh yes we're gonna
deliver the action at the adventure we
always expect from Star Wars but at the
same time we can be dark we can be
greedy uh it's it's it's a spice
Thriller you know is full of politics is
it's very complex it's about people
surviving there's not good and bad it
lives in the gray areas I think it's
going to be interesting and a fun ride
for audiences you know
finally Diego we meet a new Droid in
this and real quick yeah if you could
have any Droid from the history of Star
Wars be your sidekick like have your
back who would you have
it depends on on the moment you know uh
I think B2 the one you will meet in
under it's the perfect companion it's
pure love it's you know it always finds
its way you know he's always next to you
it doesn't matter you think you left him
at home and you turn and he's there you
know it's it's beautiful but uh
but oh my God if you're gonna go on a
mission you do want k2so next to you you
know so it's I mean I wouldn't I
wouldn't I would take them all you know
I would just get a yeah a big trunk to
to keep them all with me
that's awesome hey thank you so much for
your time and it looks it looks amazing
So Far Rock was my number one and this
looks so great man congrats thank you so
much thank you for this ciao